the aaron rodgers situation
uh
look it's going to continue to be at or
near the top of what we talk about miles
until it gets resolved
now
one thing i've noticed
moving
possibly
toward as it relates to this is
it looks like guys who know him
and who have talked to him whether it's
john kuhn the former fullback of the
packers or james jones the former
receiver who played with rogers and the
packers
they're
potentially serving as surrogates
to get out
this idea that
this is all fixable
and
it's all overblown
and
this may be
the
beginnings of
the aaron rodgers back pedal
and
an effort
if he doesn't get what he wants by way
of a trade
to show up and play for green bay for
another year because they really do have
him in a box and this gets to the point
that sims and i started making yesterday
morning miles you and i haven't had a
chance to talk about this directly
the idea that from the packers
perspective if this guy wants to retire
so be it
so be it
we'll take back 30 million dollars that
you have already been paid we'll avoid
giving you 14.7 million in salary this
year
and so be it fine
you don't want to play fine
uh and maybe that's actually better for
the people who run the team than it is
to trade him because no matter how many
draft picks you get aaron rodgers is
still going to play for someone else and
make you look bad for moving on from him
maybe by winning a super bowl and
matching the number he won in 16 years
with the packers or maybe by winning two
or maybe after two or three years the
team that he's playing for releases him
and he ends up with the vikings or the
bears or the lions not that that's
unprecedented as it relates to a former
packers quarterback so
i think he's starting to realize that
number one they're not going to budge
number two they may prefer
retirement to trading him
so number three he needs to find a way
that he can
moonwalk his way right back into lambeau
field and i think that the stuff from
[ __ ] and jones
possibly is that that signal that that's
what may happen
sure and look if that's the case then
great but you know i i think you're
right that essentially these guys seem
to be functioning as surrogates and it's
almost like you know you're tuning into
cable news and you're watching somebody
talk for a politician it's a little bit
weird when it comes to an athlete
especially when that athlete has plenty
of platforms to go on and just speak for
himself right i think you know mike
you've been saying this i think for the
last week that we probably need to hear
directly from aaron rodgers and i think
that that would probably clear a lot of
these different things up that people
are saying you know whether it's man
does uh aaron rodgers want to get the gm
fired and now it seems like oh you know
this thing is gonna back off a little
bit because uh that's what james jones
is saying and that's what john kuhn
saying it's not really about all of that
it's more that aaron rodgers has issues
yes but they are fixable if that's the
case let's hear from aaron rodgers let's
hear him say it and i i think that that
will be very valuable for everybody
involved because if he really does want
to get back with the packers mike then
that's gonna be a good avenue to try to
make that happen or if he realizes that
he has to be back with the packers then
him saying something anything is
probably going to be able to help that
and if he keeps his mouth shut and the
surrogates continue to periodically say
what they're saying for as long as media
will be seeking them out then when
rogers does show up he can just kind of
shrug and that kind of loose
calm
yeah you know there's always things that
we discuss and there's always
disagreements that you have in a
relationship that lasts this long and i
think the media made too much of it and
kind of like what he didn't stop
listening
don't waste your time reading that crap
but yes exactly the last time this
this fire started he put it out two days
later i just think that he's he's put
himself in a weird kind of a spot here
and maybe it'll die down
maybe maybe
it it at some point we turn the page at
some point something else is going to
happen that is going to capture our
attention
and at that point
maybe this just
fizzles out
until he shows up
for off season workouts otas mandatory
mini camp you know within the next month
or so
we'll know whether or not he's taking an
aggressive posture we don't have to wait
for training camp mandatory mini camp if
he's not there that's our sign that
something's going on so
i just think and i know that people in
the media that i trust that i've spoken
to about this and we kind of kick around
ideas
there is a sense that he's just gonna
act like
this is no big deal once he realizes
he's in a corner and he's not willing to
write a check for 30 million dollars and
give up
football
before he's ready to give up football if
the choices are play for us play for no
one
he's going to play for us
he's not going to go home take his
football and give back nearly 30 million
dollars to green bay packers incorporate
it because they'll happily take it and i
think you could argue
it is better to get the 30 million and
not have him play than it is to get the
draft picks not get the 30 million and
have to watch him play and worry about
what he's going to do and worry he's
going to end up back in the nfc north
miles and you know another piece of
evidence in this regard i know it's not
on the rundown but i want to mention it
shefty trying to walk back the idea that
he
got the information
last thursday
it's claiming that he already had it
when his tweet and his story both said
the league and team sources told me on
thursday or whatever well
look
there's an effort a broader effort i
think
to make aaron rodgers
look better than the situation to date
has made him look and whether it's
kuhn's comments whether it's jones
comments whether it's
shefty trying to make his report seem
like something other than what it was
you know
an effort by rogers and his camp
to get this out on draft day which i
firmly believe
this is all setting the stage for rogers
to kind of do the
what's the big deal
yeah it is but i i think we could even
go back to uh saturday at the kentucky
derby when mike tarico said that he
spoke to aaron rodgers and aaron said
that he or he tarico characterized him
as being disappointed that the story had
gotten out in that way right i think all
of this sort of
seems to
go into that that that thought that
aaron rodgers wants to be thought of in
a good light at least by packers fans
because of course you remember tarico
even said that aaron rodgers emphasized
how much he loves the packers fans and
how much he's loved his experience
playing in green bay and things like
that so again i i think that with all of
the different avenues that there are for
players to say what it is that they want
to say in these days all aaron rodgers
has to do is like turn on his phone and
make a two minute video right jj watt
did that when the texans released him
and you can look at any youtube star in
the world
all they do is they turn on their video
for about five minutes and then they say
whatever it is they want to say so it's
not like aaron has to go to some news
outlet and say hey i want to do an
interview now he can do whatever he
wants to do on his own and in his own
time i just i feel like at this point if
he really wants to tamper things down
and turn the temperature down on these
things just say it
yeah and and that that video if he would
make one would have a couple of million
views just like that and again tarico
also said there is a fisher there is a
chasm between rogers and the front
office
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports